من جانب اخر قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان وحده
النقل العملياتي التابعه له نفذت اكثر من
ال500 عمليه اجلاء للجنود جرح في معارك
القطاع من جهتها قالت صحيفه ديعو احرونوت
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يتعامل منذ بدايه
الحرب مع الاف الطلبات من الجنود الذين
يطلبون المساعده النفسيه واضافت الصحيفه
ان اعراض الصدمه التي تصيب الجنود تشمل
الارق والسلبيه والقلق والذعر وعقده
الناجين ما يؤثر على ادائهم في المعركه
واشارت الى ان الجيش طور بروتوكول اسعافات
اوليه عقليه مصمما لتعليم الجنود كيفيه
مساعده زملائهم الذين تطورت لديهم صدمه
الحرب اثناء القتال وقال مدير مستشفى رعو
لاعاده التاهيل في تل ابيب في مقال بصحيفه
جزم بوست قال ان الحرب خلفت تحديات او
خلقت تحديات كبيره لدوله اسرائيل في توفير
اعاده التاهيل العقلي والبدني للمتضررين
واشار الى ان هناك زياده في عدد الحالات
للعلاج للاشخاص الذين ساءت حالاتهم بسبب
الحرب مثل الالم المزمن واضطرابات الاكل
والعجز
الجنسي معنا من غلاف غسم مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري نجوان قبل ان اتطرق الى ما
ذكره الجيش الاسرائيلي بخصوص المصابين هل
سجلتي ورصدت تطورات ميدانيه جديده في من
حيث انت في غلاف
غزه نعم وسيله بالفعل ما يظهر حاليا في
عدسه الكاميرا هو انفجار جراء قصف مدفعي
نفذه الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل فقط يعني
في هذه الدقائق وانت تتحدثين سمعنا اصوات
انفجارات وقصف مت فعي استهدف مواقع مختلفه
لكن هذا واحد من المواقع في منطقه بيت
حانون شمال قطاع غزه وقياسا بالايام
الاخيره الماضيه هذا اليوم ربما هو الاعنف
من حيث تجدد القصف المدفعي بعد توقف لفتره
عمليا يعني في الاسابيع الاخيره ونحن نرصد
هذه المناطق الشماليه كان فيها نوع من
الهدوء النسبي فيما يتعلق بالقذف المدفعي
لكن منذ ساعات الصباح هذا اليوم لم يتوقف
تقريبا هذا ال القصف ومره اخرى قياسا في
الايام الاخيره الماضيه طيله الوقت كانت
هناك انفجارات في مواقع مختلفه وعمليات
قصف طالت واستهدفت مواقع سواء كان في بلده
بيت حنون وايضا في بيت لاهيه وكان هنا
ايضا تحليق للطيران الحربي ومسيرات
عسكريه على نحو منخفض تحديدا في هذه
المناطق هذا بالاضافه الى اشتباكات
بالرشاشات الثقيله نسمعها منذ صباح هذا
اليوم تحديدا في منطقه بيت لاهيا وايضا في
منطقه جباليا الواقعه الى الجنوب والشرق
من منطقه بيت حانون طيله الوقت هناك ايضا
تسمع اصوات اشتباكات متواصله ومن الواضح
ان هناك اشتباكات دائره ما بين قوات
الاحتلال وما بين ال المقاومه ال فلسطينيه
في الساعات الاخيره الماضيه دوت صافرات
الانذار مره اخرى في بلدات الغلاف تحديدا
شرق قطاع غزه في عينها شلوش ونيم لكن لم
يبلغ الاسعاف الاسرائيلي عن سقوط شضايا او
قذائف في تلك ال المناطق وبالتالي على
الاغلب سقطت في مناطق مفتوحه او تم
اعتراضها من منظومه القبه الحديديه لكن
على الرغم من ذلك مثل هذه الاطلاقات تعود
و
تذكر اولا بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه تواصل
التصدي لقوات الاحتلال سواء كان في ارض
المعركه داخل غزه ولكن ايضا تواصل اطلاق
هذه القذائف والصواريخ باتجاه هذه المناطق
الحدوديه من جهه اخرى وسيله هذا اليوم
ومنذ ساعات الصباح كان لافتا ايضا اغلاق
العديد من المناطق في منطقه غلاف غزه
الجيش الاسرائيلي والشرطه الاسرائيليه
كذلك نشرت عده حواجز عسكريه واعلنت عن
مناطق باكملها مناطق عسكريه مغلقه ولاحقا
اتضح ان هناك حدث يشارك فيه عدد من
الاسرائيليين يتعلق بالطبيعه ومن اجل ذلك
كانت هناك حاله استنفار امنيه وتم تامين
الشوارع من اجل تامين هذا ال الحدث من جهه
اخرى هناك طبعا حديث متزايد هذا اليوم بعد
ان كشفت قناه التلفزه الاسرائيليه الثانيه
ع يوم امس عن ان القياده العسكريه في
اسرائيل وعلى راسها رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش
ورئيس قسم شعبه الاستخبارات العسكريه
ورئيس القياده الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد يعني بداوا يفكرون بتقديم
الاستقاله ولكنهم لا يريدون الاستقاله قبل
ان تنتهي الحرب والنقطه الاهم هي انهم
يريدون التاكد ان القياده السياسيه التي
ستقوم بتعيينات جديده هي ليست القياده
السياسيه الحاليه وهذا فقط يعكس عمق
الازمه والثقه بين القياده السيا
والعسكريه في اسرائيل نجوان فيما يتعلق
بما كشف عنه الجيش عن تلقيه الاف الطلبات
من الجنود الذين يطلبون المساعده النفسيه
واعراض الصدمه الى اي مدى يؤرق هذا
الموضوع الجيش
الاسرائيلي احنا لازم في
يعني نعم فقط اذا نواصل سماع قصف مدفعي
متواصل بخصوص هذا الموضوع يوم امس نشر في
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان قسم التاهيل
النفسي في الجيش الاسرائيلي تحديدا تعامل
مع 3000 جندي منذ بدايه هذه الحرب طلبوا
الدعم النفسي والعلاج النفسي لكن فقط في
الثامن من الشهر الماضي كانت هناك معطيات
اخرى في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تتحدث
عن ان 9000 من الجنود سواء كان في الجيش
الالزامي او قوات الاحتياط توجهوا وطلبوا
هذا النوع من الدعم النفسي والعلاجات
النفسيه وهذا اليوم في مقال مطول لصحيفه
دعوت احرونوت يتحدثون الى اطباء نفسيين من
الضباط الذين تم استدعائهم في قوات
الاحتياط لمرافقه الجنود خلال هذه الحرب
يتحدثون عن عوارض وظ وظواهر صعبه للغايه
يعاني منها الجنود الذين شاركوا تحديدا في
العمليات البريه داخل غزه وهناك مخاوف بان
ينعكس هذا على اولا التعامل على المستوى
المدني بعد عودتهم واندماجهم في المجتمع ل
ان هناك عوارض لعنف وارق وبكاء يتحدث عنه
الجنود ينفجرون في البكاء لمجرد اي شيء
يتذكرونه ايه هذا وفقا مره اخرى لمقابلات
مع اطباء نفسيين تعاملوا مع هؤلاء الجنود
هذا بالاضافه الى قضيه التراو او ال
الصدمه والذعر والقلق وقله النوم التي
ايضا يخشى الجيش بانها تؤثر ايضا على
ادائهم في المعركه وبطبيعه حال هذا واحد
من الجوانب
المقلقه لهذا النوع من الاصابات في الجيش
الاسرائيلي لانه ربما الاصابات الجسديه
وسيله يسهل نوعا ما التعامل معها على
المستوى الطبي لكن مثل هذه الظواهر سيكون
من الصعب حصرها والتعامل معها نحن نتحدث
عن اعداد كبيره من الجنود شاركوا في هذه
العمليات وجزء منهم كان في داخل غزه
لثلاثه اشهر متواصله ومن الواضح ان ما
راوه وما عاشوه من حاله خوف ايضا وحاله ل
قنص وقتل الجنود برفقتهم يؤثر كثيرا على
الوضع النفسي لهؤلاء شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان
سمري مراسلتنا من غلاف غزه